foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar chip
cytometry multiplexing practical
approachable spatial biology
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by canopy biosciences to learn more
please visit canopybiosciences.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker J
Spencer Schwartz product manager of Chip
cytometry instrumentation at canopy
biosciences
Spencer welcome you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you very much and thank you
all for kind of tuning in and having me
um so uh what kind of prompted this uh
talk or maybe uh a way to introduce this
is um
uh the concept of spatial biology is is
certainly uh it's uh it's a Hot Topic
it's very interesting and people are
starting to see the power of being able
to uh not only deeply phenotype a
particular cell set or find a you know a
very specialized cell set but also give
that spatial context to figure out
what's going on uh within a a piece of
picture uh tissue rather considering its
entire architecture
um so coming at it from that point of
view uh this is uh uh very new
um and it's also very interesting
um but what I would like to do today is
kind of give that whole uh conversation
a little bit of context
um so maybe to start this off I'd like
to
kind of relay a bit of a story here
um so uh before uh canopy biosciences I
was a uh a advanced biosystems
specialist for a a larger uh
instrumentation company so one of the
final demonstrations of equipment that I
did was for someone that was it's
probably going to sound pretty familiar
but they had a piece of tissue it was
ffpe was archive tissue they had stained
it with 12 different stains and they
wanted me to use my piece of equipment
to unmix those 12 signals and give them
a spatial definition essentially of what
was going on with those 12 signatures
um so I didn't know it at the time uh
but actually what I was doing uh was a
demonstration that I could uh use my
piece of equipment uh to perform a
technique called cytomap uh so any more
cytomath has kind of become a staple of
uh this sort of spatial uh spatial
context work
um so you know this very similar concept
where we're going to collect
fluorescence images we're going to use
image analysis in order to Define cells
and then we're going to arrange those
cells uh into phenotypes and then cast
those phenotypes back into uh their uh
back into the tissue so we can see
what's going on
um so all this is really to say that you
know this is uh though uh some of the
methodologies are absolutely Cutting
Edge uh the intention really has been
around for a while people have wanted to
Multiplex uh uh cellular signals for a
long time
um so the thing to consider is that you
know really multiplexing is is not
necessarily new
um it's just that the man uh the uh the
techniques rather were relatively manual
relatively slow in order to build up
those data sets uh so really what um you
know technologists have been able to
bring to this field is a way to do this
in an automated fashion a way to do this
at you know very high Plex so kind of
naturally that brings a discussion to
well how how high plucks can you go uh
what is the best resolution that you can
give me uh these are valid questions uh
and these certainly have their uh have
their place within the context of you
know this whole kind of a spatial uh
spatial biology in general there are
certainly reasons why you would say you
know generate very high Multiplex cell
Maps uh very high Multiplex
um
uh complete tissue architectures um and
there's very successful programs where
they've used these Technologies uh to
their
um uh to complete these
um but there's still room most
definitely for people that are just
getting into multiplexing so someone
that maybe has a research question that
could use multiplexing in order to
answer it but that doesn't necessarily
mean that you want to be a lab that
specializes in multiplexing or that
specializes in spatial biology
um so what I'd like to go through uh
with you for the next uh half an hour or
so
um is uh this idea that ships cytometry
and the instrumentation for that is
called the uh the cellscape but that
these are a really nice Tool Set uh for
somebody that is getting into spatial
context but doesn't necessarily again
want to specialize in spatial uh spatial
biology
uh so again you know the the three
things to consider as as this
information is presented is is number
one that you know multiplexing is not
new uh the main methods just need to be
automated
um very key to this is that most
research questions if we're going to
cast these as a set of markers or a set
of signals that we're looking for uh
most researchers already have those
signals in mind they already know what
they're researching or what they're
looking for they just want to do this in
a multiplex fashion so it's not that you
know anyone in particular really wants
to put 80 markers onto a piece of tissue
just to see what happens it's really
typically that you're trying to figure
out a particular mechanism or a
biological mechanism within the context
of everything else that's going on uh in
a piece of tissue so that's really again
kind of what chip cytometry and the
cellscape provide and the last Point
here and this is kind of ancillary to
the uh to this talk but really very
important to this methodology in general
um is that faster higher Plex uh larger
field of view all of these things
they're really only important if you can
maintain your data quality so everything
that comes Downstream of that and
everything that'll be archived for those
you know uh computational studies you
might do uh even years from now uh
definitely benefit from very high data
quality the best or better you can get
uh the better your final experiment will
be
okay
a little bit of even context from that
so what is chip cytometry in general so
Chip cytometry is uh is a way of doing a
cyclic immunostating so that we can
build up very very large sets of
biomarkers
um so we're looking at a piece of uh
piece of tissue here that is uh
a colon section on which we've actually
stained 15 different biomarkers so the
way that we do this is through iterative
Bi-Flex staining so one to five markers
uh we can use third-party commercial
vendor antibodies in order to uh achieve
this and we basically you know if we
want this set of 15 we would build up
these as sets of 5 10 15 at a time and
we collate those images together
um so some kind of collection to
analysis here
uh the first thing we do is we we stain
for and collect these uh differential
image sets one for each marker we then
use image analysis in order to Define
what a cell is within this image and
then also then assess for the expression
value of each of those markers that we
stand for we then cast that in dot plots
so bivariate dot plots the very same
thing that you would see in flow
cytometry it's actually the very same
workflow you would use in flow cytometry
where we're going to apply Gates and
then sub Gates and then Sub sub gates in
order to Define uh these different cell
populations
and then the key to that is once we've
defined our cell populations again
through you know known ontologies this
is the same workflow as cytometry
um flow cytometry
uh we can then cast that information
back into the image and actually tell
for each of these cells you know that
this is a CDT cell because in our gating
we know that it's cd45 positive CD3
positive CDA positive but CD4 negative
and we can make phenotypes just as uh as
extensive as you would like to so that's
the idea
uh the one additional thing that will
bring you to this with cellscape is now
we can do that at much higher resolution
and much higher throughput uh so this is
actually from kind of our Legacy
instrument and this is more akin to what
you would get out of our our kind of
current offering with sales kit
um so very large field of view uh very
nice high resolution images
um one thing I love to point out here is
that for KI 67 you can actually start to
see you know uh some uh transcript
counts and things like that so it's
actually very very high resolution but
still keeping the throughput so again
the basic methodology really has not
changed much for chip cytometry uh when
we introduce the cellscape which is this
year so we've still got the same uh um
it's a cell the same methodology rather
that we've been using since 2009 but now
we can just do it faster we can do it in
an automated way
foreign
the meat and potatoes of today I would
like to talk about here
um so the the things that again you know
kind of make all this happen uh are uh
HDR Imaging uh very importantly this
idea of using the phones you know that's
really kind of uh that's the heart of
being able to take somebody that has an
idea for a project what they would like
to use spatial biology for but don't
really have the uh don't have the
experience of of using those
methodologies and walk that person uh to
a place where they can actually
successfully use these Technologies this
is really key to that
um in the last part of course is to kind
of hit on because I I personally think
this is really important is just this
idea of improved resolution uh and also
uh not then
um detracting from the throughput to
gain the higher resolution
okay
so kind of introducing the side idea of
what we call open source reagents
so the actual workflow of cytometry
chemicals like this we essentially take
you know any any piece of tissue
essentially anything that you can
section so this includes ffpe archive
tissue this includes fresh Frozen tissue
anything else that you can think of that
you can you can fix in the section is
something that we can use with chip
psychometry and again that's rather
unique in this uh particular Arena
because a lot of times all the chemistry
that then comes after that is very
specialized to a specific case use case
rather in our case we we don't do that
so we really can just just about look at
anything uh with uh with a multiplex on
top of it uh just to mention too this
actually technology actually came out of
trying to emulate what a flow cytometer
does uh so in taking that approach we
kind of get as an added benefit
um the ability to actually do this with
cell suspensions
um so we do this a lot rather with pbmc
cell suspensions a lot of our work is in
i o
um where we're putting a essentially a
sell smear on one of these chips and
then going through this same iterative
standing approach uh and phenotype
collection uh but with cells
um as a we haven't had a good use case
from a customer yet on this I'd be very
excited if anybody would be interested
in this
um but you know this gives a great
opportunity rather to take a look at
circulating versus resonant immune cells
because we can do match samples truly
match samples uh we this is something
that we can look at as well but kind of
an aside there so once we have your
sample in the chip though we would break
up uh your Plex into five Plex stainings
meaning if we had like a 40 Flex that
would be eight sets of five
we're going to stain for those five at a
time we're going to image those five
signals on our uh on our piece of tissue
uh we are then going to photo bleach
this is truly just additional light um
so no more uh uh damaging than you know
a piece of tissue in a in a bright room
uh but we're going to use Photo
bleaching in order to erase that signal
and then we're going to stain with an
additional five plus so it's the cyclic
uh staining cycle of uh of staining and
imaging and auto bleaching stain Image
Photography
one thing they kind of mentioned about
this too is uh we can also store these
samples kind of mid uh mid project
um in order to
um basically archive them so we can what
we can do and what we often do is we
might stain for say a 15 Flex
um gather whatever information we're
going to gather from that 15 flex and
then actually kind of rationally plan
our next set of experiments
um so we had a really nice use case of
this recently with a pilot where someone
did just a typical kind of immune cell
uh profiling scheme uh one of our
standard panels we offer
um really liked what they saw but then
they wanted to go back and actually in
this case we were looking at induced uh
uh an induced uh cancer model and they
had a marker for those cells that were
cancer we could actually just go right
back in and using the same sample in the
same data set at on top of that uh the
marker that was required to uh to see
that to see uh who was a cancer cell and
who was not so really nice work uh work
excuse me use case that we're working at
currently
foreign
so again you know what what really
Powers this uh is this idea that we can
really use any antibody
um so we have very very loose rather
strictures on what you can what you can
look at
um so as long as your antibody or your
signal can be excited using UV Vis
excitation as long as it emits a signal
that can be seen in UV Vis this is
something that we can use
um so you know most of what we uh oh
excuse me it also has to of course be
photo bleachable so this is actually
covering kind of most early gen dyes so
things like bitsy things like PE things
like uh for cp5 5.5 these dies that are
often seen as not uh particularly good
for microscopy in general they're
actually great for chips cytometry
because we actually want something that
photobleaches quickly
um so we have a huge Archive of uh what
works and what doesn't that we often
walk people through uh when they're
putting these assays together or using
these written person
but um generally speaking it very much
kind of opens up the uh
um your uh ability to look at individual
markers so kind of taking that a step
further in that you know
uh if we take a look at kind of
comparing chip cytometry where we truly
can use any antibody uh versus what I'll
just generally call proprietary
detection but really what I'm referring
here to is you know uh oligo conjugation
or chelating agent conjugation
um the one kind of uh you know dangerous
thing about these uh these methods is
that essentially you know if if that
conjugation doesn't work and uh every
indication we get is that it doesn't
always work the issue is that you then
you can't use that antibody
um so you can imagine that for you know
most use cases people that are using
actual research uh this is kind of a
deal breaker or can be rather
um especially since it's also very
difficult then to uh confirm once you've
added a conjugation to your antibody
that you still have the same anagenicity
that you had before so that is certainly
not always
um so you know taking the chip cytometry
approach the first thing we typically
look for is uh is just preconjugated
antibodies so there are a lot of these
out there and actually there's more and
more by the uh by the month I would even
say because vendors larger vendors are
starting to realize the power uh in
spatial biology of having these uh uh
these primary conjugations because you
can employ these uh spatial biology
methods uh in general uh much more
readily
but let's say you can't even find a
pre-conjugation or this is an antibody
that you uh generated in-house
we can always use conjugation kits if
that doesn't work we can of course just
rely on secondary detection uh and if
that doesn't work we've even had you
know more clever strategies like why
it's instructed in
um and even uh more interesting
conjugation or I would say strategies in
general
for adding a die that then photo
bleaches
the one kind of interesting use case I I
find here is in the case of this uh af48
and anti-af48
um use case
uh so here we actually have an af48 a
die that does not bleach very well but
what we found is that there is an
anti-af48 antibody that essentially
quenches out that signal
um so instead of sitting there trying to
photobleach this for 20 minutes or
whatever it takes we can instead add
this antibody to quench that
um to quench that signal almost
immediately so again it's just you know
it's it's one more tool that we can
provide our customers and uh in order to
get particular signals or particular
markers uh into into a multiplex lots of
different options and we rely on these
all the time when we build uh build our
panels
um the major benefits of this though and
again this is this is very much kind of
coming from the the perspective of
somebody that's trying to get into
spatial biology
uh the first is it becomes much more
easy to validate your multiplexes so
again because all we're really modifying
is uh the uh what we're conjugating to
or the signal uh we have a much less
abstracted
um view of uh of that signal when we
actually apply it to a piece of tissue
um so for better for worse uh the gold
standard for most IHC work or most if
work even is still you know just IHC
staining in single Plex uh the reason
being this is still what is used
clinically uh in order to make diagnoses
so there's there's very little point or
it's very difficult to make the case
that
um your uh your signal of interest uh is
is is useful in your Multiplex if you
can't validate that in single Plex and
most of the time that's done with IHC
work
um but what's great about uh chip
cytometry is that again becomes much
more direct
so here I can I can directly again
compare and this is a work that came out
of the Bush lab
um last year um I can directly compare
through serial sections uh the the
signal that I'm seeing in Multiplex here
we're looking at box B3 uh cd8 CD3 on
Panasonic keratin same signals on the
right but I'm looking at a direct
comparison between the two and this
becomes very important
um uh and actually kind of uh uh it
builds on top of this idea of doing this
in pi Plex instead of say 40 antibodies
at a time because it's very easy to tell
what cells are what and you can imagine
here especially in the i o case
um that it can be actually fairly
difficult to discern whether you have
the right signal on the right cell if
you're just looking at a bunch of immune
cells that's not always relatively clear
or that's not clear at all sometimes
when you're looking at a lot of cells
that have roughly speaking the same
morphology so the closer you can get to
a direct uh I'm kind of a direct
correlation between the
immunofluorescent stain that you see and
the IHC stain that you see the better
and that's essentially what chip
cytometry provides is almost a direct
correlation between those two so it
becomes very very easy to validate these
uh these marker sets
um the next thing it allows you to do
really is again because we're using
um the same antibodies that are being
used for other projects other use cases
it becomes very easy uh to uh add what's
uh I kind of refer to here as novel or
exotic quote-unquote targets
um but you know from the the Viewpoint
of somebody that's making these large uh
um spatial biology assay sets um even
anything outside of the clinical uh
setting could be considered kind of
Novel or kind of exotic so you'll see a
lot of times you know the if you look at
the history on pretty much anybody's
facial biology platform uh their
development history typically it's
something clinical and then it goes into
something that's a murine model and then
maybe whatever else happens to be
interesting to them
um so the ability to go straight into
even you know a mouse model and that
first image I showed was actually a
mouse spleen uh can be considered kind
of a specialized Endeavor uh so you can
imagine you know if you have anything
outside of that even you know if we're
looking at plants uh which is something
that a vast majority of researchers look
at uh suddenly it becomes very difficult
to find uh particular markers for a
spatial biology platform so again we
obviate that entirely by just using the
same antibodies that you would buy from
BD and bio Legend and cell signaling
um so this is kind of our our
showstopper use case for this um but
this was a report uh this was in cell
reports uh 2019.
um but the intention here was that uh
they had uh these mate cells which are
uh immune Associated uh invariant T
cells
um and they had a pretty specific uh
question answer which was um you know
they they had rather a a function
proposed for these cells uh they thought
that they might be
um uh associated with uh tissue repair
um but and they did a lot of kind of
higher Plex
um uh uh non-spatial analysis in order
to prove their point so things like
RNA RNA scope
um
and uh excuse me the uh in Nano string
uh to kind of in bulk show that this did
in fact happen or they thought this
happened but it was all in vitro
evidence so in order to find uh in situ
evidence they actually went back they
found clinical specimens people that had
this disease and they used chip
cytometry in a panel of about 30 markers
in order to positively identify these
maid cells so these six signals that
we're looking at here are actually a
down sampling of say 30 that were
required to positively identify these
cells and what they showed through chip
cytometry is that yes indeed these cells
are in the proper place in order to have
this function so it's a really nice
gypsychometry in general is a really
nice way to bring in C2 evidence uh to
your to your research program
um kind of the last part of this too or
another kind of benefit of this is it
also provides uh just because of the
architecture of the platform very easy
way to combine multi modal techniques uh
so kind of the the quote-unquote Holy
Grail of of this
um spatial biology is really the
combination of RNA as well as protein
and if we get RNA DNA protein
essentially as many uh omics readouts as
we can
um but a lot of people are starting with
RNA in general uh because they're just a
very good uh very compatible rather with
DNA
um so kind of that that first use case
is simply you know uh signals where it's
it's relatively difficult to find an
antibody that works well for a piece of
tissue or that marker uh or
alternatively there just hasn't been one
that's developed uh so in this case this
is uh CD3 of course that's not the case
there we're just showing that the the
methodology works well
um but it's an easy way to combine uh
through uh through relatively simple
combinations of fluorescence
um combine these marker sets so this is
useful again for things uh markers where
you have a loose signal it's also useful
for markers and spatial contacts that
don't necessarily correlate well to a
particular cell but they still may be
very interesting if you consider things
like cytokines you can stain for
cytokines with if and IHC but it's
almost impossible to take a look at that
stain and then associate that with a
particular cell and say in this case
like I know that all this stain around
here is coming from this cell
however if you can look at the
transcripts you can see which cells are
lighting up for a particular transcript
for a cytokine and that's better
evidence of a better spatial context
rather than just looking at the ifs name
of the of the marker particularly
um there's other use cases that we have
that are very interesting here too so
taking a look here
so you know what if uh what if your
sample is is just barely a tissue so we
had a really nice webinar that was put
on by my colleague uh Hagler recently
this is on our website but this was
actually taking a look at thrombosis so
this is a an association of cells uh it
is kind of a loose Association most
people consider this not very well
organized
um but that's actually the key uh um the
key thing we're kind of looking into
here is you know what what is the
spatial organization of these from uh
the sun ropes found BOCES so we've just
started this uh this program we should
have kind of a continuation of this
webinar coming soon but basically using
chip cytometry we could start by first
um you know using our ffpe know-how in
order to section these onto cover slips
so that we could look at it in a spatial
context in the first place we've gotten
as far as showing that with the cd45
scene the DNA that we can locate
individual cells and now we're working
on kind of this low Plex or single Plex
rather de novo marker meaning in our our
power line is a new marker uh qualifying
that so again you know we can go through
and look at these at single Plex if you
want to to see where these individual
markers are the one thing that I find
very interesting here is some of these
cd154 These are actually platelet
specific markers so we can even take
this outside of just nucleated mammalian
cells that things that are kind of truly
exotic uh within the kind of the spatial
biology context so this I found very
exciting but it all kind of goes to that
same idea that you know if you already
have a research program and it happens
to use something that's outside of the
clinical space it's kind of a shame that
it's different difficult as it is for
most Technologies to use multiplexing so
really what we're providing here is a
way to easily you know take your two or
three signals uh or markers or
mechanisms that you're interested in and
study those in a truly station context
so that I find particularly exciting
about this platforming this technology
[Music]
um the last part of this so you know I
each of these sections I'd like to kind
of bring back to like okay we we have
this thing called the cellscape what
does this provide
um so again kind of that first slide
describe uh this idea that we uh you
know that uh multiplexing has been
around for a while but the issue is that
a lot of these methods are are really
manual
um so what this cell stage actually
brings here first and foremost is a way
of automating these stains so you can
imagine if you have you know five stains
at a time that's not that big of a deal
however if the intention is to add 30 or
40 different markers onto a piece of
tissue and do that cyclically uh
suddenly that becomes kind of daunting
um so we've uh included automated
automated essentially an automated
stainer along with the cells gate that
does that for you so we can actually
program in up to 75 different reagents
uh each of these vials will take up to
five for five five plus cocktails and we
can go through and then apply these
image them photo bleach and do that all
automatically uh so again that's you
know up to 75 if we wanted to do it
completely walk away and of course we
can you know we can swap out these tubes
uh and essentially do an unlimited Plex
number
[Music]
okay
um so the next part of this is uh adding
but I refer to here is kind of
biologically relevant data so this is
kind of split into two parts uh the
first is the introduction of this
technology called the HDR Imaging
and the second is is simply obtaining a
very high spatial resolution uh Imaging
so starting with HDR why do we need HDR
here
um so you know we're still using a
microscope in order to image an is
signal so there's certain you know kind
of limitations to that particularly if
you talk about you know in typical
context you're talking about a single
exposure
um so the basic problem is this is that
you know if I use a very long exposure
to capture say quantitative image images
uh regarding a very dim signal so
um that's kind of the that's the typical
trade-off here so if you have a very dim
signal we're going to use a camera to
capture that signal we have to use a
very long exposure however when I do
that
um I'm going to essentially over
saturate anything that might be brighter
than that low signal alternatively if I
have a very bright thing that I'm
looking at that necessitates a very low
exposure which is of course going to
under saturate these stem cells so you
see where you can kind of get yourself
into this kind of ketchup 22 where no
particular camera exposure can catch
both the bright signal as well as the
low signals so what we're looking at at
the right here is a this is a CD4 cells
kind of a cell smear so CD4 on pbmc is
what we're looking at here is actually
trivariate so most of these pbmcs don't
actually Express CD4 at all uh some of
them Express a dimly those are monocytes
and some of them are blazing bright
those are T cells so what we'll walk
through here is an exposure Series where
here we're taking a relatively low
exposure in order to get nice contrast
on our bright cells
so this next slide then is adding an
additional longer exposure and what I'm
marking here by this white arrow is the
addition of this little dim cell here
that was actually missing entirely from
the uh the original image that you saw
so as I add more exposures you can
actually see that we're adding more data
to the scene so it's the same cells it's
just all the the only thing we're
changing is the camera explosion uh but
you start to see something else as your
exposures get uh relatively speaking too
long
um so this white here is actually over
saturation so anywhere you see white
I've actually topped out the camera I'm
not getting any quantitative information
about that so if I take this all the way
to its extent
so here I'm looking at the entire scene
I've got you know all these cells uh are
lit up but you can see I get quite a bit
of white here too so again there's no
single exposure that can actually
capture the full extent of the
expression on each of these cells and
the same thing happens with tissue as
well
so what it means is you're actually
truncating by picking a particular
exposure you're truncating the data that
you're getting out of that sample and
there's no specific you know Perfect
Exposure you're either picking bright
cells or you're picking themselves
so you know generally speaking this this
has real consequences when you take it
to the phenotype uh so when you take
this to the phenotype then so again this
is taking a look at data that's made it
through the entirety of our pipeline
where we're looking at expression each
of these is a cell uh we're looking at
their expression of cd8 versus CD3
um so these uh double positives here are
actually cd8 T cells what you'll notice
this is some of our competitors data
this is actually this population is
entirely missing and again the reason
for that is not necessarily the you know
the Acuity of the system uh spatial
Acuity or the ability to collect low or
high signals it's just that
um a a I would say in this case a longer
exposure was picked in order to uh to
find that which then oversaturated uh
these high cells so all to say that you
really do kind of need multi-exposure
Imaging HDR Imaging in order to
um
absolutely uh kind of give an absolute
quantification to uh to your cell
populations
um and this is being seen in other kind
of a core lady correlated rather Fields
as well uh David brim has just put out a
paper that shows that you actually see
the same effect in IHC uh when you're
scoring between say a three and a four
versus a one and a two
um that the scoring uh ability is
actually much lower for that high three
and four uh case differentiation again
because you're essentially over
saturating the uh oversaturating the
signal
um we also see this in general
fluorescence where people uh like uh the
uh the Massachusetts general assistance
biology Corps is taking a look at this
time focal microscopy and collecting
multiple
um different essentially exposure images
at once uh just in typical microscopy
um again because it you know it
increases your ability to do
segmentation later down the line it
increases your ability to see you know
dynamic processes that might be
happening that are over several orders
of magnitude and intensity it's just
it's a very useful and better way to
collect images
um the other half of this then is
uh is really kind of high spatial acuity
um so what we're looking at here is
essentially kind of right to left
um so this at 10 000 nanometers per
pixel this is kind of the information
that you get out of say a Geo Nets and
the reason we use that as an example is
because that's really one of the first
kind of key uh spatial biology
Technologies uh again based on
transcript elements but we can see the
actual resolution that you get out of it
is uh is is pretty low
um and they even you know they state
that really what they're looking at is
kind of a functional group of cells not
necessarily a single cell which is fine
um if you take that a step further down
to a thousand nanometers per pixel this
is uh roughly speaking what you can get
out of cytop again you know a very uh
long a spatial biology with a long
history
um steer you know you can see you could
probably make out the difference between
cell borders but it's relatively
difficult to assign a particular signal
to a particular cell here if we take
that to 500 nanometers per pixel uh
there's current spatial biology
platforms that offer this kind of
Technology uh here too you know you can
get a pretty good idea of what's going
on but this really is I would I would
stop this at
um really saying that this is cellular
or single cell resolution
uh what we're very excited about here
with cellscape is that we actually take
that to 182 nanometers per pixel uh so
here what I'm trying to Define here by
this wide Arrow
um is you can actually see kind of sub
cellular resolution or subcellular
details you know so instead of just
saying well this signal is on this
particular cell we can actually start to
say well this cell uh this signal is on
this particular say organelle that in my
opinion is very exciting again because
you know we can do this uh on mass and
in an automated fashion
um so even though
um you know the the argument goes that
we really don't have the ability to
analyze for this right now uh I would
say any more that that argument that was
even made in January along those lines
really doesn't hold anymore because of
all the uh interesting things that have
happened with artificial intelligence
even over the last year over 2022. so I
think we're going to very quickly uh see
that we do gain the ability to do true
you know kind of on mass but single cell
resolution uh which is pretty exciting
um so again kind of what is uh ending
with What the cells gate bring to this
um so you know you can always attain
higher spatial Acuity um you know you
just get a a higher and higher numerical
aperture objective uh a better quality
objective rather
um the issue is that typically when you
do that you're you're typically reducing
your field of view
um so in uh spatial scanning or
attaining a spatial uh if you want to
basically collect the entire tissue uh
we need a way to uh um a scan across uh
scan across the tissue and collate those
images so that's the way almost all of
these Technologies work if not all of
them
um so if I wanted to collect this entire
piece of tissue that we're looking at I
would have to build this up through
individual fields of view here so really
what we're showing here so this is I
kind of picked this as a a typical case
but this is an orca Fusion kind of a 2K
by 2K 6.5 pixel pitch camera this is
kind of a typical camera so to speak so
out of this it would take about 21
fields of view in order to capture this
entire piece of tissue and you would get
about 325 nanometer pixel sampling
edited so again you know this first
number 21 fields of view that's
basically how fast can we go
um the on the right uh 325 nanometers
that's how nice an image can be
generated
um so what cellscape's bringing to uh
this equation then is actually not just
better Acuity uh better spatial Acuity
rather but actually it does this faster
so we can actually collect the same 182
nanometer pixel resolution over just 15
fields of view so again you know the the
less pictures I take the faster this
process goes
um and you know that's that's definitely
a goal but again we don't want to uh we
don't want to sacrifice spatial cues
with that so one of the things that
cells gate brings to this equation is
again the ability to collect very very
high spatial Acuity data but do it
quickly
um if we're okay with a little bit of a
hit uh to resolution but we just want to
go even faster still uh we have another
modality for this instrument where it
can actually collect the same uh uh area
of tissue uh in just three or so fields
of view and actually still maintain like
uh 365 nanometer pixels
uh so again you know we are able to
generate uh with open source antibodies
and uh
HDR Imaging uh both a very high spatial
Acuity image and then also do this in a
high survey or a high throughput mode
which is pretty exciting
kind of the last thing we add to this is
um you know again just for the idea of
uh multiplexing and easy use we have a
large pix or a large rather uh Imaging
field so that you can properly utilize
that faster speed uh and we also have
the ability to do this uh in a sets of
four so we can actually image and
process up to four samples at a time
um another fun thing I find about this
is you can actually also do four
entirely separate experiments if you're
interested in that because all these
fluidics are actually independent
um the last part to kind of hit on here
is uh the idea of data analysis so I
know this is is a major concern for
people as well uh because collecting all
this information is one thing but again
you know you you have to be able to
utilize it and that's what I've seen as
a major uh kind of hurdle rather or uh
you know large activation energy to Labs
that are not specialized in this field
um is they don't necessarily know what
to do with the data after they've
collected it so essentially what they
have is a large collection of images
um what the heck do we do with this
um so to kind of discuss that I've uh
I've kind of mapped out our entire our
data analysis pipeline here from
beginning to end
um but the idea is here that you know we
collect these HDR series uh we then uh
we collate those into uh
uh a single HDR image uh for each of
those we then collate every single
channel that you put together
um and then we uh we do a background
correction so you get a true kind of
normalized or a true uh
a true idea of what the the signal
that's actually coming from your
um from your marker uh from there then
internally we have a segmentation tool
that actually tells you where cells are
within that image and then we have a
further fluorescence calculation where
you simply use bivariate gating in order
to assign self-notypes and then you can
cast that back into the campsite back
into the image
um so the idea of showing all this is
really you know the the key to
um kind of the key to generating that
that understanding here is is knowing
what the pipeline is doing and then also
uh you know giving people those
uh hooks into the data pipeline uh so
that they can use this stuff to their uh
kind of utmost Advantage uh so in our
case you know we we have a way to export
essentially every single step of this
roadmap so if you do have image analysis
export
um we uh we can export say these guys
are selling me tiffs only tips are about
as open sources you can get most if not
all image analysis Supply force is going
to take them if we take this all the way
through to the analysis we can even give
you the analysis output as a CSV so
things like sidomap can use uh can use
uh that data uh but again we try to make
this easy and try to make it as open as
possible
so that is kind of described here but
just you know just some concrete
examples of places to go with this type
of data and I like to point these out
because a lot of a lot of the these
types of data sets that are coming from
competitors you can do the same thing
um but uh if if you have someone that
knows uh Indica Labs Halo or you have
someone that knows Vizio Farm even NIS
elements um these are all programs that
work well with our data set they work
well with most data sets
um additionally I definitely uh I point
out another kind of newcomer to this
field which is enable medicine uh so
enable medicine actually does this all
in the cloud they use this with uh very
very large compute uh server schemes uh
in order to get through what can be
sometimes very massive amounts of data
um so instead of you know setting your
laptop uh to run a particular essay for
you know over the weekend A lot of times
they can get that same task done that
same analysis task done in you know
hours
if you're looking uh again for a kind of
open so open source uh uh or freeware uh
schemes these are just as important
frankly because they're often the tools
that are most
uh these are often the tools that are
most
um uh developed by the community by the
research Community we have ways of
hooking into those as well so again you
know my solid recommendations for single
image analysis are definitely image J uh
kind of a new ercomer is a cue path
qpath is a fantastic way of looking
these larger uh whole slide image uh
acquisitions
um and even cell profiler which
basically takes um uh it's more useful
for cell
um cell suspensions uh and uh
uh
sorry for
um
not necessarily intact tissue with lots
of different phenotypes I'm sorry lots
of different morphologies but it is
another way that's well accepted to look
at individual tissues
um the idea being basically that you
know we're uh we're very much uh again
with that open source and in our uh
intention of providing this data
um
making it easy to use this data rather
we want to be as compatible with as
possible with other tools so that you
can use those tools and the resources
around those uh the best that you can
[Music]
okay cool and this is uh
[Music]
uh in this final slide I was just
mentioning that we can again do the same
thing with just the uh the post analysis
or uh post analysis data as well so if
you rather do our entire analysis find
phenotypes find the cells that have
those phenotypes you can then use that
information uh to put those into cluster
Maps uh in whatever else is uh
interesting to you and do that very
easily
okay
um so uh again kind of wrapping up what
uh what we really find to be the um the
important uh aspects of um kind of
spatial biology for the masses uh is you
really need to be able to use versatile
reagents uh you need to be able to use
those from trusted vendors so again
there's no particular reason especially
if you use cyclic immunostaining like we
do to reinvent the wheel rather by using
specific conjugation schemes to oligos
or p-lining agents or anything
um
uh the next part is uh you know you
really do need to be able to use uh or
collect rather what we call biologically
relevant data but really what that means
is you know you need to collect the full
breadth of expression uh on a particular
marker as well as high enough Acuity
spatial resolution uh to sort of future
proof this particular data set because a
lot of times people do collect and maybe
not analyze until six months or a year
from now and you really want to be able
to keep up with those analysis pipelines
if you can
um and the last part is really again
kind of you know chip cytometry is a
methodology uh cellscape is an
instrument uh so what cellscape really
brings to this equation is a an
instrument that's uh specifically geared
or specifically engineered for chips
cytometry in that it provides you know
quick automation of staining quick
scanning and all of this is kind of
seamless
well cool with that I really appreciate
your time and I am happy to answer any
questions that you have here
take a look at those guys
thank you Spencer um very informative
presentation and as said we will now
start the live q a portion of that
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
started so our first question is how
many units or instruments are installed
absolutely
um so for uh chip cytometry in general I
would include our Legacy instrument as
well as our our brand new cellscape
um so Legacy placements are uh R50 so we
have 50 of these instruments and we've
actually just placed our first cellscape
here in the United States
um at uh in the Anderson we also have
another couple that are on the way that
are going towards Europe as well so I
would say in general to kind of answer
that question for you if if you search
for the term chips cytometry that'll
bring up you know kind of every
institution that's that's used it for
the most part
um as well as kind of our Publications
as well and I think we're up to like 35
or so uh Publications or uh published
abstracts I should say
great thank you
um and then the next question someone is
asking I would like to apply for a grant
for a project using trip cytometry would
you recommend a lab contact where I
could send the samples to be phenotyped
due to due to not having equipment on
site
absolutely so what I would suggest is
instead if you could reach out to and
just contact canopy biosciences the
reason I uh I would give you that too as
an answer is because that can kind of in
parallel uh give you access to those
labs that have this uh instrument to
kind of negotiate that and then also
talk with one of our Representatives
about our pilot program so we have these
data sets already available that are
they're nice curated data sets they're
we're happy to tell you everything about
them and they're not uh curated I guess
I don't mean they're you know
photoshopped to death or anything like
that but they tell a story and they give
kind of the complete story of chip
cytometry
um and then on top of that of course
yeah we have a pilot program where we
can take your samples for and it's
specifically for things like uh you know
Grant submissions and things like that
so the best thing to do is really just
to put an inquiry into a
canopybiosciences.com and we can get in
contact with you
thank you next question here is what
would be the pros and cons compared to
doing single cell sequencing and I have
you compared the results from both
techniques
yeah so um uh kind of a funniest side
there maybe not so uh chip cytometry and
uh I should say excuse me uh canopy
biosciences uh is actually uh there's
two heads of our business one is the
instrumentation half which is cellscape
uh the other half that was a cro Wing um
so that's maybe something else that the
audience is interested you can contact
canopy uh biosciences for for rnac for
Nano string for chip cytometry even you
know kind of uh more clinical facing
things like IHC and if we actually do
all that stuff
um but in doing so actually we are we're
starting to do internal comparisons
between single cell uh uh rna-seq and
our in chip cytometry
um the major difference again is that
rna-seq is going to give you that answer
in bulk whereas uh Chip cytometry is
going to give you that answer as as a
single cell within the context of the
other cells that are around it uh so the
really the idea there is like do you you
know do you need spatial biology or do
you just need the bulk transcriptomics
or the bulk transcript uh you know uh
uh increases and decreases and a lot of
times the answer is well yeah I need
both
um so uh at least with the canopy uh in
in in total rather we can actually give
you both of those answers um it'd be
wonderful to maybe talk about a project
with you that uh we would collect
information like that
um the other thing that I found uh very
interesting is there are quite a few
methods presented at U.S spatial biology
as well as there's a really cool
conference called sbi2 where uh Labs uh
it's actually the Nolan land
particularly uh that is looking at
methods for combining these two types of
data sets uh in silico which is really
really interesting because it means that
you could take your say 15 and 20
markers combine that with an RNA seek
you can actually get a much more
Exquisite answer uh for for both data
sets I find that really exciting
great thank you
and for one more question
um what are other benefits of increased
resolution
yeah sure
um so increased resolution in general
um
there's uh so there's two major benefits
that I see here so the first that I kind
of pointed out there is specifically in
the case of what we're offering versus
kind of a competition as we see the
market anyways right now is it's it's
really that jump of saying that this
cell has a marker on it saying this
organelle has a marker on it so right
now uh fully admit this is an analysis
that we can run in bulk like we would
need to do in order to you know say we
do this with chip cytometry uh however
you know kind of with some of those open
source tools I talked about there are
certainly people within the research
community that can do this and they
can't do it right now
um that once it come Niner I believe the
the Allen Institute has a really cool uh
um uh program where they do uh analysis
programs like this
um but again being able to answer those
types of questions and give those types
of questions a spatial context is really
really exciting in my opinion
um the second that we've seen kind of
concretely um is that it actually
increases your ability to do uh just raw
segmentation uh so again you know all
these Technologies if we're taking a
picture we have to somehow get
um the information out of that picture
as to what is a cell uh so that's called
segmentation uh the higher the spatial
Acuity is the easier it is to actually
segment those cells and we saw this in
development of the skulls gate where we
actually went from say 500 nanometers of
resolution to 182 and what we found was
that we were suddenly getting
drastically lower uh
um expression values and the reason we
were getting those is because when you
segment on a kind of a fuzzy uh image it
gives you a lot more leeway as to what
you're calling um kind of the borders of
a cell it was actually including more of
the signal of Interest which is in the
membrane so when we had better
segmentation we found that we actually
had to then increase the size of that
binary to once again include the
membrane because we were segmenting two
finally uh close to the nucleus
um so it's you know maybe illustrates
the point but again the idea is like the
the better spatial Acuity that you have
in this image the more that you can do
with it with image analysis
I'd say the same thing goes for HDR
Imaging uh the higher the
um the range of signals that you have
the better that you can do segmentation
on as well
thank you again
um Spencer for your time today and your
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor canopy
biosciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye